my birthday this is my fault
we've been friends for about a year
right he's very pretty but very stubborn
he loves cuddles he loves string and he
loves chicken today we're gonna try a
sweater I guess that we'll both be
wearing he's not gonna stay still for
very long so I really don't know how
this is gonna come this is the sweater
how do I look
it's kind of big but I guess it's kind
of cute and then does he he just goes in
this little pouch II oh it's kind of a
small bird come here I know maybe you'll
like this because you're so tired right
now
can we go inside this is just like sex
I jumped ahold of him it's okay you're
not falling please hold your butt I'll
hold your butt okay okay so we're gonna
try all day of this we shall see that is
up ten he's shedding everywhere cap
pouch cap but pouch there's a dog
all right don't you love being a
kangaroo cat nope hello ma'am
your [ __ ] hair this should make your
like furry itself so guys it's yeah
that's it basically just carrying your
cat but you're have to wear a sweatshirt
yeah you said to be sweating
[Music]
I like ceilings what aren't I doing she
loved this is a cat it's hard because
he's so independent you know he's not
doing what he wants to be doing right
now what do you want to be doing rice
ball he wants to be his own man so I
think maybe this could have worked if we
were just sitting at home chilling on
the couch and he wanted to like snuggle
up and get cozy I think that could be
possible I mean look at how much she
should this is a cute sweater and I
looked like a cute cat myself and this
was some nice bonding time with us but I
think it would work better if it were on
his terms luring
[Music]